you make like a tree
socialism
Sharia
end everything bad these were the
ingredients chosen to create the perfect
leftist but Professor [ __ ] accidentally
added an extra ingredient to the
concoction progressiveness
thus the squad was born using their
Ultra superpowers AOC ilhan and Rashida
have dedicated their lives to fighting
America and the forces of freedom
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I know
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
can't taste anything that must mean I
have the vid
but have the old covidia the old
Blockbuster Co video no you don't no I
don't I don't know I have uh I do have a
slightly scratchy throat because uh we
were doing a show so
what bed yeah bed quarantine him all
right everybody sorry
okay so vid
[Applause]
we have a lot to get to today my
handsome's gonna be a little bit of
weird I think it could also just be my
ears are blocked I think it is yeah yeah
everything sounds like I'm in a wave
pool right now we have a lot to get to I
don't know if you know this Elizabeth
Warren is now calling for an
investigation into Jared Kushner
who's the son-in-law of uh president
Donald Trump and also with you a little
bit of anti-Semitism going on there but
I don't know if you know why perfect
timing because right now we're finding
out that Hunter Biden remember he's not
right he's not president but it turns
out he was funneling a lot of money to
his dad former Vice President Biden a
lot we now have what more texts emails
from the infamous laptop I don't know if
it's number one two or three uh so we'll
be talking about that there's no denying
it anymore uh criminal Vice President
Biden we know he's criminally insane now
he's just plain old criminal we'll also
be talking about Florida uh Banning some
math books not Banning just prohibiting
them from being taught in a curriculum
and uh comparing it with you know
Banning I don't know To Kill a
Mockingbird from the left because this
is what we're going to be talking about
all day before I move on to any of that
uh let me ask you this what song
question of the day would scare you most
to be heard at thirty thousand feet
above sea level if you were on a plane
I want to hear yeah I just want to hear
like what is it that would maybe you
know raise your cackles
free Fallen it's a good one or uh if
they're playing The Ultimate Warrior I'm
Gonna Take This Plane into a nose dive
hook
oh you're like why is Ultimate Warrior
flying this that's yeah I don't believe
I don't believe he's FAA certified uh
yeah for two reasons one it's terrible
right yeah just the pilot changing work
can you check me lower no no no no
higher is this a parody and we're gonna
die oh that's a really weird way to tell
us that he wants to kill himself also
let me tell you this before anything
else I we did not do a show on Thursday
we told you that we weren't doing a show
on Thursday but this was last Thursday
shows all this week if you don't see us
on YouTube we haven't let you know we're
still streaming live Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern just go to
rumble or go to mug club or we have an
entire basically double the show
double mint show okay
oh also I should tell you that uh well
before that let me move to is that done
Gerald hey how are you I'm well how are
you sir I have a sore throat I but we
already know that did yeah I know did
you sleep well I just want this no I
didn't sleep that well it's hard when
you can't sleep but when you feel like
you you know you just uh performed
performed services on the device from
Seven ah and uh you know him you love
him at Landau Dave he's going to be this
Saturday uh in Virginia Beach doing
shows and uh then uh it's a funny bone
and then him and I of course our June
18th Pikes Peak Center in Colorado
Springs there are a few tickets left
Tulsa is sold out we apologize Dave how
are you good Ahoy sorry about the
services Dave's a lot of focus on me
well you know what Saturday's shows went
late he might be a little hazy he might
be a little hazy from the wormwood
liquor Dave's a little hazy from the
wormwood liquor man now
that makes your throat feel better
[Laughter]
well they asked me at the show they
asked an encore to do Gilbert Godfrey oh
and uh I honestly I was starting to tear
up because I missed it was really hard
so I'm like and what
was still gonna make me do this I was
glad you did it though I wanted you to
do it they're like yes we paid for a
ticket you must dude you must do Gilbert
Godfrey dance joke manga come out little
symbols yeah okay
of this this is just to show you and
again none of us here are condoning the
depravity of the world but we do have to
address it Casey guys don't know
we are all happy Warriors here but
that's what you see that's after the
processing in the morning our morning
and mine starts like at 4am is waking up
reading the news and going son of a
[ __ ]
I just cry and then we somehow have to
turn into something that you know you
don't have to react that way
so Duke University it's their uh
Divinity Pride the hell is that you'll
see they held their first worship
service uh where uh they worship God the
great queer one I'm not making here we
go super
[Music]
good morning the holy and queer one be
with you
we want to affirm everything
they truly are to step into the holy
one's fire that burns away all that says
we are not good enough
and refines Us by the Pentecostal fire
to be who exactly the great queer one is
she gonna start speaking in swollen
tongues strange one yes fabulous one
fluid and ever becoming one from a busy
night
allow us to make our ideas of you into
an idol you are as close to us as our
own breath and yet it looks like you're
out it sends all that we can imagine
you are mother father and parents Elton
John's biggest jacket brother and
sibling you are drag queen and trans man
and gender fluid incapable of limiting
your vast expressions of beauty ah yes
the great drag queendom of the Lord why
do they know the words why do they yeah
exactly they've done this before yeah
it's like drag queen you're commenting
on the Lord's clothing well by the way I
thought you said he's genderless that
means he he's gendered and going the
other direction you can't be a drag
queen if you're a female there's no
you're just a girl oh yeah you're just
you know the great asexual one I guess I
don't know where to get to heaven it's
just God doing the time warp yes this is
bizarre Saint Peter just walks up time
is fleeting yeah I want yeah strange
you're Riff Raff
weird I had no idea I love how they say
let's not let our ideas of you uh create
you into an idol and then you talk about
his clothing yeah then you make an idol
of him yeah completely an idol
completely an idol with a all complete
with a Prada sponsorship I'm just
kidding whatever the big and tall shop
is what is it Talbots what I don't know
what they wear them out of school now
please I don't want them getting any
further education
they're dangerous enough as is it's just
so you know you just I know you don't
believe that you're right where's the
Kool-Aid when you need it yeah I know
really oh my God why aren't you guys all
wearing the same black outfit in a pair
of Nike yes exactly
yeah
I think your ship is above just create
your look just just create your own
religion there you go just do that just
don't call it just create your own
religion if you want God to be a queer
genderless queer drag queen which is an
oxymoron just create create your own
religion and nobody will join yeah and
he will smite thee appropriately yeah
have beverages Jim Jones had him yes
exactly yeah I'm just I'm not saying do
those no no no when you're saying like
beverages you could have available
Refreshments yeah Refreshments yeah
because this never ended poorly gosh
okay
and look I actually want to hear from
you if you're watching and you're an
atheist uh you don't have to write
because it's hard to hear you over the
screams of hell so comment below
what use I'm always curious what
atheists think when they see this
because we have you know a lot of you
watching are atheists who are sort of
Christian sympathetic because you
understand that it's foundational
judeo-christian principle principles to
Western civilization
do you understand like when people talk
about appropriation yeah it's like oh
yeah I'm gonna take your God and hey Joe
Louis come on go back ah all right you
know heck can someone come in and get
Joe Lewis he doesn't want to be in here
today even that look do you see that
clip upset him that quickly it's uh it's
not his fault that clip upset him really
not his there you go all right go ahead
Joe Louis because it's only going to get
worse
laughs
so on the same uh same topic ish uh
there's a pastor Jack Jones Jr and just
to be clear this might have been a
private Charter plane but it's been
making the rounds and I want to discuss
Elon Omar who by the way married her
brother all references available at
lotto.com it's true
Pastor Jack Jenn's Junior
um made news uh this organization uh
Kingdom realm okay is that what is
kingdom real Ministries I thought you
would have no idea you're a donator
right chair yeah I'm a charter member I
thought you had cash just hidden in your
wall and stuff uh pretty much yeah what
do you think your 10 goes yeah don't you
have a bathroom with 500 Grand in it yes
who doesn't Dave uh first one Among Us
so Kingdom realm Ministries they were
filmed playing music uh on a flight to
Germany so here's what first went viral
and then I'll give you the response
which is hysterical
and come on
[Music]
now before I go to uh there were some
negative reactions from Elon Omar let me
remind you that she married her brother
uh her ex-husband brother share the same
name birth date this is overlay A1 even
Snopes called this claim unproven and
that's as good as they can give you
by the way it's your job to figure it
out detective Snopes it's in the name
Snopes for crying out loud yeah Columbo
look I don't know it's not natural what
are you waiting for those kids to have
hooves you're not Colombo anymore though
you don't even have to wait no how great
would meet him if Peter Falk worked at
Snopes he's like is she married her
brother yeah
I looked
betrayal yeah I tried not to look so
congresswoman saw that nice Christians
was playing music I can't look at
whether you're a Christian or not it
seems fine uh tweeted I think my family
and I should have a prayer session next
time I'm on a plane how do you think it
will end the implication there is of
course if you heard a Muslim call to
prayer on a plane
right that people might be more nervous
that one
yes yeah yeah I think there's I I think
there'd be two big problems with that
yes
I didn't I don't know no
when uh Jars of Clay drove a postal
truck into the World Trade Center
exactly yeah we all remember when uh was
it Creedence walk on water yes Revival
hijacked a plane yes yes when Sandy
Patty flew a 747 into a mega church
right yes for that yeah yes Zach Sabbath
would hijack yes if you play best of
Hillsong backwards it says blow up
American
mm-hmm that's weird Jesus cougar melon
Christ I don't know Christian bands yeah
absolutely not
I know a couple a DC Talk DC Talk I was
on a flight one time in Indonesia
largest Islamic country Jesus Freak him
out people were wearing like all the get
up and Garb and chanting the entire time
and I looked at a friend of mine at the
time I was like we're not getting off
this plane no you're not we're not
making it of course it would make you of
course it would make you nervous because
that's what people have done
historically when they've blown up
planes I know what you're saying what
about all the people who do the call to
prayer who didn't who didn't blow up
planes I get it that's that's most of
them right at the very least a plurality
of them but those aren't the ones I'm
primarily concerned with it's not a
double standard it's just setting a
standard yeah don't get me wrong if blue
blue tarsity walked in grabbed his
guitar bash against the wall and handed
him back the neck I would find it funny
yes I mean I'm just saying it's a bit
annoying if if one if that's a charter
flight there was people in the seat like
as they were panning like really again
jack yeah I'm sure there's plenty of
people that were like yes I believe in
God too I bet you Jesus would like quiet
on a plane yes
I'm sure Jesus is like not now son he
doesn't control everything he put up the
no smoking sign yes yeah
it looks like it might have been a
private plane too looks like it might
have been or a mega like a mega church
like a charter to fly I'm sure they knew
him yeah I doubt some guys just grabbing
the old guitar ain't gonna play right
yeah
no
no
Spirit Airlines that's not not on my
play but you say Spirit we're talking
about it wasn't the spirit because we
would have used the guitar to hit
somebody to get a big front seat ah I
think it might have been no Soul Plane
yes full of redheads
that can possibly get yes when the
guitarist was offbeat but look this is
this is a perfect example I don't think
that the left understand they don't have
any self-awareness at this point we'll
get to Elizabeth Warren in a second but
this is just how lack how much of a lack
of self-awareness they have they're
making your point for them take the
worst Christians you can possibly
imagine I mean the Westboro Baptist
Church they're of course not Christians
there are 12 members they're in red four
of them have flippers just
but even then if someone stood up with a
bomb vest a turban on a plane and said
and just stop and shield God hates facts
and sat back down like I got off easy
and we're supposed to go like yes well
what kind of prayer session is she going
to have diversity is our greatest prayer
session grab hands and pray yeah if any
Christian was praying that'd be fine
we're not talking about that we're
talking about the chanting that you
typically do before blowing I wish I'd
me I wish I might bring me your brother
to bang tonight she already got that one
she's got a wish for something else I
want another ah no give me give me I
need give me give me Allah I need I need
I want kids that are gross
please I'm doing the work I'm not the
slacker uh name that movie line comment
below always helps with the YouTube
algorithm here's something else while
we're talking about all the holy stuff
going on right we just hit the lesbian
queer one God we just hit the uh
here's the thing even if you're an lgbtq
aaip person yeah you don't want a
lesbian God but don't you also because
lesbians aren't fun you want a gay guy
you also don't like gays yeah yeah no
but gay God would be fine you know you
gotta be fine a little bit catty you
know you you would expect that some of
your confessions would get around you
know like buddy Cole yeah but a lesbian
God
beat yeah and just be self-flagellation
all the time and shopping at Orvis now
during Holy Week uh it easily triggered
yes
a group of Muslim migrants from a local
shelter they pelted Christians with
rocks
um at an Easter this is the thing at an
East it's an Easter procession in Spain
and local migrants I'm sure you can
guess uh hit them with rocks just watch
Ed
[Music]
it yeah
[Applause]
hold on all right other than that lady
saying that did you guys happen to catch
the this guy walk walking through which
guy do you see the the pointy hat up
there to the left maybe oh oh
what in the Spain
that's like when
yeah just look in the top left of the
clip as it pans left in just a second
not right there it goes back
Oh wrong meeting my bad
is it Tuesday oh it's Wednesday
maybe he was just wearing it to throw
them off the scent so they'd throw the
Rock and hit the point yeah
oh I guess this Sunday we don't have the
area all right
well look look it actually it's not the
Lions Club it's a public prayer
procession which by the way is being
attacked by Muslims I could have sworn I
got off the plane in Alabama and is this
not Alabama okay
does it means something else in Spain it
well I hope so is there a cultural Gap
here it actually does I've got some
notes on it because is that like is that
like the the national Siesta mascot this
is this is Garb from an order of
Catholic penitence who apparently were
the order of penitence was a religious
order established uh by Bernard of
Marseille Marseille sorry about 1272 for
the reception into the Roman Catholic
Church of the reformed courtesans guess
what I don't care you don't get to wear
that anymore no we just walks up sorry
guys laundry day uh yeah this was old it
was my great grandfather so I had look
what you didn't need to put on the hood
it's separate well I mean come on I
don't want to not match
discreet about it it's just at a certain
point I mean if Wendy's has to release a
new sign like you guys just have to
Rebrand you don't get to keep it even as
a clan hat it makes no sense if you have
to go in anywhere you have to take the
mask off and reveal yourself take it I
can't see with this mask every time I
walk in anywhere it knocks off you just
don't it's like if I don't know it's
like Bill Burr show up to a stand-up
special in the Eddie Murphy Raw leather
suit and I was like I had it first it's
like it doesn't matter
this is my leather suit
what just get some black guy stole it
come on yeah it's like having the
toothbrush mustache you're like no it's
mine first it's like well no it's
Hitler's now yeah you don't get to wear
anything no no it's mine sorry Laurel
party whatever one probably already that
guy's really lucky the cops started
beating someone otherwise yeah yeah he
probably was just waiting for a
distraction and he's like now's my cue I
could walk away just nothing to see here
guy in a big Hood I'm just lights across
nobody saw me and also in Spain not
exactly a lot of the people that you
hate there I don't think hey how many
times have we seen uh in America like uh
people Pelt uh Muslims uh with rocks
because Illinois was just talking about
it yeah it's so terrible I mean is this
not a hate crime I would think so it's a
crime but you know I don't believe in
hate crimes I'm saying by their standard
yeah yeah yes it's a hate it's a crime
born out of love Stephen yeah well that
guy's love for hoods can't get enough of
them apparently I don't even care about
the incident at this point I just want
to speak to this guy and be like you
know what that is that's right come on I
don't okay imagine having to explain
what you're wearing to everyone you've
ever met yeah no it's not what you think
it's this I'm sorry yeah yeah that's
what we heard no Google it before you
hit me yeah it's like some guy who's
family crest is a swastika and he has
around his suit arm he's like it's not
this is a Scottish no it's an arms coat
I just was way before yeah this Point's
shorter yeah it's not and I have to put
it I have to I only put it there because
otherwise like otherwise I can't move my
arm if I put it where it's down too low
so I gotta just it's not it's not Hawk
Wings it's Hawk Wings not Eagle yeah not
Eagle yeah it's a different bird of prey
yeah we don't
I mean I don't necessarily like them but
I don't yeah you know exactly I mean I'm
oh no yeah no I just like Jews but
that's not what this means yeah that's
not it was about not enough to get a
tattoo no no no no no
and I don't have a tattoo but that's why
I go full body cloak
so all right let's move on to this this
is something that the media is
discussing and they're discussing very
dishonestly
of course uh you know I repeat myself
but this is uh important because I think
it also draws a contrast between
when people try and say oh the right has
cancer culture as well look I think
cancel culture is overused I think what
we mean to convey and this is one of
those issues where I don't think we want
to be reductive I understand that sound
bites work for people what we're really
discussing with cancel culture is the uh
ruining of someone's not only life but
the removal of their livelihood for
opinions that you deem impermissible
that's what we're talking about with
cancel culture we're not talking about
someone being fired because they're bad
at their job we're not talking about uh
someone who is removed from government
because I don't know they they do
something illegal that's not cancel
culture what we are talking about is the
world in which we live where you are
often intimidated into silence because
you know the leftist bully pulpit will
try and remove your livelihood and we
see that all the time it does not exist
on both the left and the right they've
tried to say oh right right Wingers want
to ban books well let me explain to you
what is going on right now and then I'll
contrast it of course with the books
that the left has banned from certain
curriculums so uh the Florida Department
of Education just rejected 41 of new
math textbooks and the reason why
keep in mind the key word here is math
as in mathematics hmm
they were including things like critical
race Theory uh they were including
topics that had nothing to do with math
it was social engineering so 41 of the
books were no longer approved for the
math curriculum
I can't imagine what is in a math
textbook that would indoctrinate a child
Orange County classroom Teachers
Association president Linda dormal says
you wrote a scaffold after learning the
Florida Department of Education
54 math textbooks submitted for the
state's approved list the state says the
Publishers attempted to indoctrinate
students I'd really love to see some of
these rejected books and see what they
highlighted and found disturbing in
those books according to the state 41 of
the submitted textbooks included
references Theory Common Core and social
emotional learning grades K-5 had the
most materials rejected Governor Ron
DeSantis saying in a statement the
Publishers were quote indoctrinating
Concepts like race essentialism state
representative Carlos Guillermo Smith
tweeted saying the governor has turned
our classrooms into Political
battlefields
I can't imagine what he's talking about
according to the doe what do you mean
imagine every five years and materials
must meet Florida's Benchmark excellent
student thinking standards I can't even
imagine you're a big girl a very big
girl you should use your imagination use
your grown-up skills right you remember
the thing you read that yes I don't know
I can't imagine that you're being
ableist because of my dyslexia you're a
teacher and you can't read problem it's
not like all of this is new either it's
like listen Common Core we said don't
submit books with that and they're like
yeah but what about this guy yeah what
if we so submit all right so we'll
submit Coleman Court no no no no no no
I'm telling you don't submit Common Core
right yeah well we'll submit coming cool
so uh she's so perplexed as to what kind
of indoctrination material could be in
there now this again shows you the lack
of self-awareness on the left people on
the right right now you're watching
conservatives you of course have heard
the attack that conservatives want to
ban books right you've heard of course
to have heard the attacks that
conservatives believe in censorship
they've tried you know these attacks
you're well aware of them I know this
because when I go on campus or when I
just go out in public on a street corner
and do change my mind people who are
conservative are more educated on the
opposition's position this woman doesn't
even noticing I can't even imagine what
might be offensive well that means she's
not aware of the fact that there is
opposition to critical race Theory there
is opposition to social engineering
there is opposition a common core in
textbooks I mean she doesn't even know
that that tells you who lives in an echo
chamber so how about as an example this
entire program we've covered this before
it was called a pathway to Equitable
math instruction
mm-hmm it's promoted by the Oregon
Department of Education to teachers last
year one part of it is called uh it's
titled dismantling racism in mathematics
instruction I thought this was math yeah
well because you forgot to I did think
it was odd one had to carry the hood
well it was from the Catholic order
Stephen
a plus sign is a swastika that's not
dancing yeah exactly
it's a swastika with a flat tire exactly
that's what I've always said
what about California their proposed
math curriculum their Department of
Education reading a quote mathematics
education the United States was
initially structured for a narrow
purpose to prepare privileged young
white men for entrance into Elite
colleges a particularly damaging
assessment practice to avoid is the use
of timed tests to assess speed of
mathematical fact retention the narrow
Focus was to teach math yes the narrow
Focus was to teach math and this is
another thing I understand that back in
the day when you looked at IQ tests they
were not they were not fair because
often black children did not get the
same amount of instruction or the same
amount of time of instruction that is no
longer the case and if you look at the
outcomes with people who are in
underprivileged areas well look you
can't just say that there's a
correlation between a lack of spending
because there's more spending often in
these bad neighborhoods for example
Detroit for example Washington DC they
don't have good performance metrics you
can't complain about well the teachers
are being paid more in many of these
places these as people now are getting
further and further removed from what
you would consider systemic racism the
results aren't improving you can't just
keep throwing money at the problem
this is the issue that they have in
California oh it's because we're looking
at results here and affirmative action
isn't enough so we need to uh we need to
change we need to get rid of
standardized testing when you get rid of
timed testing hold on a second maybe
accept responsibility that you're bad at
your job but they can't do that so you
have to throw they have to throw new
[ __ ] into the mix so here's critical
race Theory being referenced by name in
chapter two
because the left says it's not a real
thing critical race theory in the
California math framework it says
rethinking teaching and learning
mathematics from a critical race
perspective where could it be less
relevant
racial Theory which by the way is
entirely incorrect for people who claim
that uh you know conservatives are
reductive there's nothing more reductive
than critical race Theory it just says
oh look uh correlation uh causation well
what about the fact that there were
actually more people enslaved and taken
to Africa than here in the United States
what about the millions of people or at
least a million people who were enslaved
in the Mediterranean
what about the kind of results that you
see in the UK by the way with
underprivileged white people and by the
way the term cracker redneck existed
before the United States was even
created what about those people who see
the same kind of performance metrics
sometimes as you see as Black America
certainly can't just be a race thing
all references are available at
lotto.com I highly recommend that you
read Thomas Seoul he talks about this in
depth he's one of the best ever the
point is you could not be more misguided
or simplistic in your approach and then
you create an entire curriculum based on
a false premise critical race Theory and
you ruin a generation of Americans
here's another one a proposed textbook
for an Arizona District says that
conservatives are more racist than
liberals and I don't think that right
now we have any specific examples from
Florida that's the issue it hasn't they
actually uh did you get a hold of uh one
right here oh did you yep yep it is a
math problem you ready in Florida this
is one that they were this is one of the
teaching yeah but let's see if maybe you
can get it well yeah okay or we'll see
why it's banned all right if a China man
it seems bad if a China man be on a debt
platform
and the A train coming how much bail
does my boy rail get for kicking his ass
onto them tracks this is from section
two lesson one huh uh
uh no bail that's right
it's a brain teaser yeah you would have
got eight in school yeah
see it's not that hard my white
privilege and so here's it this is
important because you look at you look
at what's happening here and why don't
you critical race Theory they want to
teach math from a racially charged
perspective because again their goal is
to divide and conquer great results by
the way yeah great results this is
something you can also see if you look
at for example the riots that took place
in Watts or in our hometown of Detroit
these riots took place by the way in
cities where uh they didn't have the
same kind of
history of slavery guess what the cities
weren't destroyed in the Southern United
States where they were more closely tied
directly to the slave trade those cities
were destroyed places like Detroit
places like Watts they were destroyed
guess which parts the black parts of
these cities it wasn't just white flight
in Detroit it was all flight
because the left constantly wants to
divide and conquer they want racially
charged riots they want like we see now
black lives matter if that goes away Al
Sharpton
Kamala Harris are out of a job so that's
why they want to inject race and by that
I mean racism they want to inject racism
critical race theory is racist not only
is it wrong it's racist they want to
inject that into every curriculum so
while they want to inject that and they
complain when someone who's well within
their uh Authority as governor and
certainly people who work in the state
legislature say well you know what this
is not appropriate for math is that how
you want to ban books well guess what
Democrats are busy Banning books like to
Kill a Mockingbird or Huckleberry Finn
why because the n-word is mentioned in
there even though the ultimate story
about Tom Sawyer and Huckleberry Finn is
an anti-racist story who's being
reductive
who's being reductive at this point I
don't know look you can comment below I
don't think I do not think that it's a
hypocritical position to say you know
what critical race Theory should not be
in math textbooks and I also don't think
that we should ban To Kill a Mockingbird
I think that is entirely consistent I do
believe it is inconsistent to want to
ban books
simply because their historical context
is offensive to you today
while demanding that we inject racism
into
non-sociological subjects yeah well and
don't let the left get away with the lie
that they'll tell you that the the
people on the right don't want you to
hear about slavery don't want you to
hear about the bad choices that have
been made in this country the terrible
things that have happened no we want all
of that Todd guess what it is taught
right now what you're trying to do is to
say all white people are bad right all
white people are privileged and
therefore you guys have to give to these
other groups by the way don't don't
throw Asians in there because they're
they're a little pissed off at the
Asians too they just won't say it right
sincerely it's not Asian privilege I
wonder why they're targeting math though
and making it more equitable
I don't know was that was that a Hyder
is that rhetorical question I mean it's
it I think it's uh
fairly clear so yeah something about the
agents no no definitely not I would
never say that I don't believe that they
uh understand math no they do not know
they do not excel in the stem field
that's true that's that is not why Brown
and Harvard are like no more no more
keep them out yeah they're not known for
being uh highly intelligent Asians
trying to get into Stanford are like
Urkel in the intro and yeah
days go
why do we want everything to be catered
to stupidity and I I don't mean that
anybody's stupid I mean they want to
keep you at that point no because that's
the only that's the only result they
have so far spending trillions of
dollars over decades and decades and
decades asking for more money and more
money and better unions and they have no
results so they have to change the goal
posts they have to move the goals in
history taught by the way just to be
clear when they say the right no I want
slavery to be taught but I want it to be
just full story
who had the most lives
where are the most amount of slaves
United States
Europe
Saudi Arabia right the Middle East
Africa particularly West Africa who had
the most amount of slaves a lot of
people don't even understand I want you
to teach slavery but I want you to teach
that we had to end slavery uniquely
because of our constitution saying that
all men were created equal guess what
they had slaves across South America and
Brazil there was nothing the rest of the
world didn't see anything wrong with it
yeah
so there is more of a history of racism
in the united there it is true of course
that slavery here obviously if you look
at the Civil War of course was
predicated on racism but that's not why
we had slaves in the first place it's
how people in the South who wanted to
keep slaves like the rest of the world
found justification in the face of the
unjustifiable we didn't bring them here
under the guise of racism they were sold
they were traded they existed everywhere
else and then when we said you know what
no more slaves here in the United States
there were some Southerners who said uh
blacks are inferior it was to justify a
practice that already existed it's not
why slavery was created because it
existed before and it still exists today
I want that taught if you're teaching
slavery and I want you to teach long
division not what Elizabeth Warren
demands you teach that day oh it's also
an extremely wealthy class of people
that has been put onto every single
shade of white which is very aggravating
right
and that should also be taught who was
it it's not every every single person in
this country did not benefit or uh be
hurt by the same thing yeah that's
that's the part that bothers me so much
the Italians the Irish all kinds of
people that came to the country were
treated like garbage yeah Asians in
Asians yeah I'm okay with the Italians
look I'm part Italian and I just think
if if you could just be quiet in a
restaurant maybe it wouldn't be such a
problem it's not knocking over glasses
you don't always no I get it yeah I get
it you don't have to talk like this all
the time and a little gropey
that's the Cuomo brothers so the
brothers not all Italians are like the
cuomos well
like half right hi Fredo a plurality a
large number yes okay half my uncle so
now we can move on to this uh by the way
smash that like button if you're
watching right now just smash the like
button it helps with the YouTube
algorithm if you search the title of
this show you won't find it so tune in
to watch it live smash the like button
comment all that we appreciate it so now
let's move on to Hunter Biden and uh
former Vice President Joe Biden
uh first let's let's use this to jump
off Elizabeth Warren
still a thing who by the way is less
Native American than I am sub-Saharan
African that's true we we actually have
we actually have the genetic testing
just to prove it can you imagine if I
it's right here actually yeah yeah can
you imagine just I I have like one
percent substance here in African if I
just came out since you're 23 and me yes
that's the result blank without the
lines it's just without the lines yes
yeah yeah those are well that's just
because she likes this verse well she's
one one thousand and no one calls a left
on it she comes like me coming out just
doing priors bits like
people crazy smoking cracking [ __ ] my my
new soul food
soul food book Davis greens Dave's got a
great recipe for giblets he loves a
pig's feet too long I'm gonna mess you
up you know
Curry and Dave way better than Mike Epps
in that Stu in that he does a horrible
Richard Pryor I wish I were black now he
actually does
so Elizabeth Warren
I can't I need to restart because every
time I say her name I just want to take
I want to take a pot shot well I can't
stand her she to me is just the most
annoying she's not the most she's not
the most evil that's that's Governor
Whitmer and then Nancy Pelosi but
Elizabeth Warren now today and the
timing is curious said that the doj
needs to uh investigate
Jared Kushner
foreign
so she wants the doj to investigate
Jared Kushner because of maybe some
investment from a Saudi Prince okay
Kushner for those who don't remember uh
I know last names can be confusing
Donald Trump's son-in-law Andy is a Jew
oh is she anti-semitic that's what I'm
wondering not according to one of her
books she said I think this is a moment
where Congress needs to do a lot more
about corruption okay well thank you for
giving us a Segway that's what that's
what US pilgrims call a Segway ah Segway
a Segway lying bear
bagels and locks
so now we all know how the liberal the
leftist media right they all wanted us
to make sure that we understood right
yeah that because Hunter Biden obviously
all of these scandals they wanted to
create distance between Hunter Biden and
from Vice President Joe Biden the answer
right their retort was always while the
hunter Biden's not running for president
but don't take my word for it absolutely
we should note Hunter Biden isn't
running for president that argument has
been debunked and I raised it because
you mentioned social security issue
Tyler I'm very confused very confused by
the president's son's assertion they're
really on the up and up the the top
presidency has been the most corrupt
Administration in history we would argue
his children have offices in the West
Wing when Joe Biden is elected president
let me just tell you something his
children will not occupy offices Wings
I'm sorry to to crush Junior's hopes and
dreams you know that the people who want
to make hay in Washington are going to
try to use your adult son as a cudgel
against you
how do you feel about that and what do
you have to say to those people he's
pooping well look uh oh yeah
there it is I have a great confidence in
our son
I am not concerned about any accusations
been made against him it's used to get
to me I think it's kind of Foul Play but
it is what it is and uh he's a grown man
he is the smartest man I know wrong I'm
trying to Pure intellectual capacity and
by the way uh he's saying they're trying
to get at him you know with accusations
I know these facts that we're about to
deliver are aimed at you but that's how
you know he was lying because he went
way too far that's how you really look
no of course there's nothing has nothing
to do with me if that's all he said like
hey you know it's my son you know I'm
not in charge of my son he has nothing
to do with me it's my son it's his own
thing he's just by the way he's a he's
the smartest person who's ever left
he's a member of Mensa he's a mother he
makes he makes Mother Teresa look like
look like a child rapist huh it's like
we should have then been like hmm is
this connected to you I don't know
anyway I don't know about Princess
Diana's breaks
no idea but we know that Hunter Biden
obviously we already knew that Hunter
Biden's a crappy person well but he's
super into crack right okay yeah of
course he's in the crack he tried to
smoke parm yeah well we already know
that those parmesan cheese yeah yeah but
he's a big prostitute guy yeah he's also
in bed with uh the chatcoms yeah well
okay I already know all of that but I I
just oh yeah he even diddled his dead
brother's wife okay shut up shut up I'm
trying to do a segment we all know that
Hunter Biden is a horrible crack slash
parmesan cheese prostitute purchasing
brother's widow diddling bag of scum but
this is about former Vice President Joe
Biden and what he's done and he can be
still be the smartest man that Joe Biden
knows yeah I had plenty of smart people
smoke parmesan cheese and drywall and
and bang their brother's wife it doesn't
it's not a semi-q test Dead Brother
throw guns and garbage cans as well
allegedly yeah and unless she unless you
no he's definitely so here's what we
have now the connections from Hunter
Biden
two former Vice President Joe Biden
sorry it's just that it's real it's all
real
so text message messages from Hunter to
um his daughter uh Naomi's show that
he's been funneling money to you've
heard the big guy right for decades that
was sort of the code phrase and we
thought that's all there is is the big
guy code for us at least they're using
code for it code free there's like you
know Hawk Wings not Eagle wings tube big
guy over
you know that kind of thing so that's
what people were speculating well maybe
the big guy doesn't mean former Vice
President Joe Biden well the problem is
then there are other
receipts ah that are actually written at
the attention of Joe Biden it's like a
Jesse smullet check yeah
so uh this is what he wrote These are
some of the texts I'll kind of build the
case here for you uh to his daughter
Naomi from Hunter Biden I hope you all
can do what I did and pay for everything
for this entire family for 30 years
here's another one it's really hard but
don't worry unlike pop that's his father
I won't make you give me half your
salary now let me start this off with
some low-level expenses and then we'll
sort of we'll it'll be uh you know we'll
graduate to the
the more expensive stuff that's labeled
for former Vice President Joe Biden so
some emails to his business partner a
guy named I think was Eric schwerwin
just that name makes me swear
irwini so uh emails and they were they
were titled jrb bills now I know you
have the big guy like I could be anybody
and Hunter Biden saying pops you're like
I can't be anybody and now you're like
Tundra Biden sending emails to this
partner jrb bills that could be it that
could be any person it doesn't mean it's
Joseph R by Joseph rubanowski don't
worry it gets worse Biden these are
labeled jrb bills and here's where some
of the money was going uh so air
conditioner repair okay for Joseph uh R
Biden uh 1239 that's actually a good
deal for air conditioners
I actually thought that would be more
physically irresponsible I mean it's
illegal yeah well but it's still that's
a good deal yeah uh I'm gonna need to
find this guy a painter for uh 1475
fixing a stone wall probably tried to
smoke it twenty six hundred dollars
now Sherwin at the time was president of
this it was a Rosemont Seneca Partners
okay and that was Hunter Biden's Chinese
linked investment firm
they also had access to Joe Biden's
finances and his tax return oh no that
makes sense now what we all thought that
Hunter smoked you know the cheese
because he was a dope sick Rock fiend
yes but it was really because he
couldn't afford any decent crack after
giving all of his money to Joe I don't
know the going price for crack but your
theory seems sound yeah thousands of
dollars could have been put to better
use I mean it's really not so much the
going president crack at just the amount
you use right well right yeah the keys
and the poisons in the house yeah also
the poisons in the crack
the fentanyls yeah so let's go to some
big ticket items you're like ah some AC
stone wall whatever it's still illegal
especially concerned Elizabeth Warren
wants to investigate Kushner
right now and this is something the
media will try and keep suppressed um
let's go to some other expenses where
pop is connected over the course of 11
years Hunter Biden paid former Vice
President Joe Biden's cell phone bill
totaling 25
000 also by the way uh Joe Biden you
actually qualify for the T-Mobile senior
discount you should be using that qriket
wireless yeah that only makes two calls
right cellular one that's not the only
twenty five thousand dollar exchange in
2018 Hunter accidentally transferred
twenty five thousand dollars to an
escort named gulnera and that that
actually forced the Secret Service to
show up at Hunter's hotel and a former
agent sent him messages again this is
all documented references available at
library.com telling him to he said you
need to come out and he was reminding
him that the hotel room was linked to
quote Celtics account wait Larry Bird is
involved in this too we can't rule
anything out but I should have mentioned
in this case Celtic was former Vice
President Joe Biden's call sign that was
his call sign so we have JRP bills we
have the Celtic account 25 000 that's by
the way that must be a fantastic hooker
well but yeah memo line he wrote not a
call girl right so I I think we can hold
it yeah I like Gary Springer who wrote a
call girl again it's just the lying is
too much it's like he's the smartest
person I ever know but hey was that a
hooker no I wrote I simply wrote on the
check not one
why didn't you just write why don't you
just write uh you know like consultant
I couldn't think of the word also you
used to check with the hooker is that
bad
you stay at your dad's hotel room that's
also bad yeah use cash really I didn't
know I've never thought about that I
know hookers carry Square
and again it's funny but here's the
thing it's their their depravity knows
no bounds they don't fear accountability
at all that Hunter didn't think twice of
paying a hooker with a paper trail
because he never the media is not going
to call him out and not only will the
media not call him out on it the media
read interference for him right with the
New York Post story yeah before the
election and then said by the way this
has nothing to do with former Vice
President Joe Biden uh the story was
true we know it was true that was
absolutely election meddling and now we
know that there is there are tens of
hundreds of thousands of dollars
that have gone and been funneled from
Hunter Biden to former Vice President
Joe Biden there is a connection it's
illegal yeah and whistleblowers yes and
whistleblowers well they're alive for
now well yeah for now uh it also by the
way it seems like he's doing pretty well
today good for him Hunter Biden I don't
know where he makes his money oh that's
right illegal
but that's how he affords his Swanky
Malibu mansion he's like Charlie Sheen
in uh three and a Half Men
somebody else has uh put down stakes in
the boot and that is Hunter Biden Joe
Biden he's moved to Malibu
um rented a house is that one of the
Broken Lizards I'm being serious it's a
thousand a month is that's what it was
going for what yep 20 000 a month he
moved we're told maybe four months ago
but it's been kept in the download the
reason we know is the Secret Service
which is swarming that area oh no um
that's I believe one of the Secret
Service Vehicles there are Secret
Service their jobs to keep him in the
house yeah going up to neighbors now and
they're asking would you rent your house
to us for the next year so that we can
do our thing they didn't say it was for
Hunter but obviously it was right right
across the way and they want to make
sure they can keep an eye on things but
don't don't worry that secret service
detail is only costing you the taxpayer
uh thirty thousand dollars a month
wow that's a deal at twice imagine
thinking like oh man and Robert Downey
Jr just got clean and lives in this
neighborhood how many
how many grown men are gonna sleep in my
kids race car bed yeah
so think about all of this does seem a
little it does seem a little curious to
me right so we have okay Elizabeth
Warren right now calling for an
investigation into Kushner yeah okay uh
Hunter uses his dad's political clout to
secure
um like Scrooge McDuck size bags of cash
from China and get himself board seats
uh at Ukrainian Energy company in an
insane house yes an insane house it's
the most expensive area you can live in
America basically right and then he he
also takes some of that money turns
around that the money he made off of his
father's name right and gives it right
back to former Vice President Joe Biden
right so he takes money using his name
and then gives Kickbacks to former Vice
President Joe Biden receipts all we're
gonna have them all lottery.com so that
would mean
[Music]
Joe Biden's a criminal yeah absolutely
yeah right you're right he'll be going
to jail it's illegal
for most people as in not legal yeah I
always thought illegal manager was
completely legal I am the most legal
ever
again Joe I wrote not illegal on the
track yes
that I wrote on it didn't you can't you
read
smartest guy you know by the way I know
some interesting news that I've heard
right now is that Wikileaks actually has
access to all of the data on these hard
drives and we'll start to kind of throw
that information out so I'm hoping that
that is 100 true and that we can verify
that at some point in the near future
because if it is like everything's
coming out from it right and by the way
the FBI rated remember giuliani's house
he had it right there and that was the
one thing they didn't want so think
about this so think of the this whole
it's this amalgamation of Pure Evil and
Corruption you have somebody who's uh
worked suckled at the public teat for
over 50 years former Vice President Joe
Biden who hasn't worked in the private
sector hasn't earned an honest dollar
for five Decades of his life a screw-up
son who bangs his dead brother's widow
allegedly definitely uh uses his dad's
name to funnel money back to former Vice
President Joe Biden then of course gets
caught in these scandals committing
Crime After Crime which of course not
only uh is there a financial liability
with former Vice President Joe Biden
there's of course a security liability
because it can use is leverage when
someone's committing such awful crimes
like pedophilia as Hunter Biden was like
drug use like throwing a gun into a
trash bin but instead the FBI whose job
is to root out corruption that's what
you assumed at one point right you
assumed that the FBI were the good guys
go into giuliani's apartment
and take everything else because they're
going to investigate him while leaving
the laptop which we now know is
confirmed and was also suppressed during
the election by big Tech we have the
former Vice President of the United
States we have his son and international
relations with the UK with the Ukrainian
uh well Ukrainian government by proxy
yeah we have the FBI involved doing
their bidding for them and then we have
big Tech ensuring that you never hear
about it before the election even though
we know that that verifiably would have
changed the vote in every single swing
state that exists and then they blame
you they blame you for showing mistrust
in their institutions at a certain point
at a certain point and I mean
figuratively you just got to burn it all
down and start from scratch I mean I
don't know if this is fixable this ball
of twine at this point if you think
there's a way to fix it within the
current system let me know comment below
it helps the algorithms we're going to
play Bad movie lines and apparently so
sorry actually this this just came up uh
the new I was on a roll
the new hello buttery one new woke MCU
movie Thor love and thunder trailer just
drops and we have that wait what what
wait hold on a second okay because my
mind is still out smoking parmesan
cheese twenty five thousand dollars for
a hooker with a check Michael well so
bad movie lines we can we want to show
you Thor 4 love and thunder where Thor
becomes a woman oh on Mud Club yeah well
we could do in front I think we should
do it if you want wait wait wait wait
wait wait hold on a second that's a good
idea you're right wait everyone pause
how mad is this going to make me I
haven't seen it yet this just came out
Thor changes his name to [ __ ] ah see
this is where the problem begins I think
this should definitely don't [ __ ] shame
the model I know I'm just kidding I
would never you can't pick up that
hammer yes I can pick up the hammer I
don't know I'm just squeaker should we
be doing this in front of should we be
doing this on YouTube or should we do it
on mug what if we showed it now give
like initial thoughts when we go into my
club there you go and okay how about
this be ready to piss off YouTube at a
moment okay hold on a second here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna start watching
this okay but you have to follow my
direction because I do not want to get
suspended on YouTube for a Thor trailer
yeah okay
and I don't know is it is it Thor or it
hurts
this sounds like an Australian male
strip club so like Love and Basketball
yeah
so you have to follow my instruction
no and by the way depending on how many
likes we get right now on YouTube maybe
we'll do it we'll do it let's say let's
say what do we want to say like 10. it's
10 good no let's say low let's just
let's just just hit the like button if
you want me to but we're going to start
playing this okay and then if I can feel
the rage but I'm trying to yeah I'll
just say stop it and then we'll do it on
Mud Club because remember we got in
trouble we got suspended on YouTube
because the transgender individual who
threw a Hobo's lunchbox at me yeah we
laughed at that person when we laughed
at that person committing felony battery
against me and we were the ones who got
struck so I'm very very I don't know
what's coming at me here I know what's
going to be bad but let's start it and
then if I say stop we stop and we we go
we go to mug Club if it's the little
girl from Adventures in Babysitting I'm
cool with it other than that I think I'm
gonna be confused yeah yeah all right
let's let's see let's all right here we
go
these hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
and washing my new breasts I need to
figure out
exactly who I am wait
wait oh boy this reveal is what
Judah friedlander yeah see Bubba Gump
I was running
[Music]
days
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean I already don't like it it's
because it's not my style
remember what I told you
did Marvel just buy the GNR catalog I
think just look into the eyes of the
people that you love
[Music]
all right me
what just listening
no that's those guys guys let's just
let's go to my club this is only gonna
I'm just not gonna be happy again I'm
not gonna be happy with myself YouTube
piss off YouTube piss off this is gonna
get back
thank you